mi nombre es christian valdez ramírez
artísticamente me hago llamar como chris
no vr por mitos apellidos porque siempre
una misma paz se ponía celoso cuando
dejaba uno solo el día de hoy les vengo
a contar sobre un superpoder que yo
descubrí que tenía y que tenemos todos
pero yo este superpoder lo descubrí
cuando tenía 12 años entonces tengo
aproximadamente ocho años
desarrollándolo y se los quiero
compartir el día de hoy
este superpoder yo lo llamo como el
superpoder de contar tu historia y al
mismo tiempo poder crearla todos nacemos
con este superpoder porque todos tenemos
un universo simbólico distinto vamos
creciendo y nos vamos alimentando de
distintas películas distintas ideas de
arte y de historias diferentes de otras
personas y también las nuestras
desde muy chiquita me gustaba mucho
analizar la vida de los artistas que yo
admiraba y casualmente siempre era muy
curioso al encontrar historias de como
las personas que yo admiraba llegaban a
su felicidad de cómo llegaban a contar
sus historias o desarrollar sus ideas
más grandes y más magníficas el día de
hoy que les estoy contando de este
superpoder se los narró así porque a
todos nos gusta que nos digan las cosas
como espectaculares como magníficas a
todos y sobre todo los mexicanos nos
vamos construyendo de una cultura llena
de historias de personajes que tienen
historias únicas e irrepetibles y es
verdad todos tenemos una historia única
e irrepetible y ese va a ser nuestro
superpoder
siempre encontraban historias de
personajes como leonardo da vinci y
cuando buscaba cuál es la clave del
éxito o cómo llegó leonardo da vinci
compartir tantas cosas con el mundo como
tenía tantas capacidades las respuestas
que encontraba de las personas
conformistas eran es que leonardo da
vinci tenía un superpoder y en realidad
sus dotes venían de contactos que tenía
con los aliens es por eso que él llegó a
tener esas ideas que nadie más ha podido
desarrollar o vamos a poner persona
exitosa ha llevado al éxito porque tiene
un pacto con el es illuminati o
persona exitosa tiene un don
sobrenatural que tú no tienes entonces
así es como vamos minimizando nuestra
historia así es como nosotros mismos
vamos minimizando los poderes que
tenemos y los dones con los que nacemos
y nuestra misma historia
cuando en realidad cuando empecé a
contar mi historia en el arte me di
cuenta que todos tenemos un mensaje que
a través de la perseverancia del
esfuerzo de la creatividad de la
motivación y de la humildad de saber que
todos tenemos algo más que aprender con
los años lo vamos a ir desarrollando si
practicamos estas cosas que se ven tan
básicas pero de verdad ojalá la
inspiración y la motivación llegará de
algo tan rápido como una abducción
alienígena o de algo tan rápido como que
se llegue una luz y nos inspira hacer
una nueva idea o comenzar esas cosas que
vamos pro casting ando desde muy
pequeños porque nos van haciendo
minimizar nuestra propia historia a
nuestro propio superpoder
la dedicación naturalmente crea talento
desafortunadamente el talento natural no
crea dedicación esta es una frase con la
que voy escribiendo mi trabajo porque me
he dado cuenta que el que trabaja más el
que dedica más a su trabajo es el que
llega más rápido a la meta a pesar de
que sean años y años de contar donde
constante esfuerzo
y aquí tengo un ejemplo de como en
realidad la dedicación es lo que puede
hacerte convertirte en un artista como
la dedicación puede hacer que tu idea
llegue a las personas que de verdad
conectan con eso
pero mi historia comienza a los 11 12
años la violencia del país y la
violencia de culiacán sinaloa asesinó mi
hermano a mi hermano lo asesinó cuando
yo tenía 11 años una niña que está
empezando a comprender porque está en el
mundo ahora tiene que comprender por qué
una persona le arrebata la vida a un ser
humano después de vivir esta situación
yo necesitaba que alguien más compartirá
mi historia que supiera qué era lo que
estaba pasando y a través del arte lo
encontré a través de la del arte
encontró otros artistas como frida kahlo
como van gogh que vivían cosas no
parecidas a la mía pero vivían
adversidades y a través de sus pinturas
lo contaban y así es como yo a través de
la imagen a través de eso que todos
generamos tan fácil así como generamos
un clic así como entramos a instagram y
vemos miles de fotos y no se puede
calcular exactamente cuántas fotos están
creando en este momento así fue como
empecé a contar mi historia y empecé a
conectar y generar empatía con personas
que también habían vivido algo parecido
a lo mío
bienaventurados los que ven cosas
hermosas en lugares humildes donde otros
no ven nada desarrollando mi superpoder
me di cuenta que tenía la capacidad de
seguir pensando como niña después de los
15 cuando ya yo era una adolescente me
di cuenta que podía ver en una silla
algo que yo podía convertir en una
historia en una metáfora o en un
elemento que contara algo en mis obras
y así fue como me di cuenta que todos
tenemos una historia que contar más no
sabemos lo maravillosos que somos por el
solo hecho de tenerla por el solo hecho
de estar aquí de construir nuestro
universo simbólico con distintas
situaciones que nos pasan no te
preocupes por ser original preocúpate
por ser auténtico lo que hacía famoso a
van gogh y lo que hace famoso a
distintos pintores de distintas épocas
por ejemplo van gogh lo que lo hace
famoso no son los girasoles que pintaba
no es el cuarto que pintó el que está
famoso es la manera en que lo hacía la
manera en el que llevó ese mensaje al
mundo y te quiso hablar sobre su dolor y
sobre sus situaciones
con una cámara y un control y un tripié
empecé a contar historias mías y también
de los demás empecé a contar sobre
personajes que se parecían a mí y
algunos que no tenían nada que ver
conmigo entonces empecé a crear
historias empecé a desarrollar
personajes empecé a sentirme conectada
con otras personas que contaban el mismo
universo que yo y así es como ahora creo
autorretratos que creo retratos donde te
voy contando lo que estoy viviendo y lo
que siento que también están viviendo
otras personas
y hablando usted de esta frase que es
preocúpate por ser auténtico y contar tu
historia a través de esto les quiero
contar de este personaje que ha cambiado
mi vida y que llegó muy lejos mi carrera
este personaje se llama ofelia está
inspirado en hamlet de shakespeare
cuando yo escuchaba sobre este personaje
era muy difícil encontrarme con un
personaje que suele ser cliché con un
personaje que está contado miles de
veces en la historia del arte cómo voy a
hacer ese personaje mío cómo lo voy a
hacer único voy a encontrar lo que hace
que me parezca ese personaje voy a
encontrar como shakespeare se inspiró en
contar esa historia y volver mío a este
personaje encontrar lo que se parece a
mí
ofelia y yo somos una misma en esta obra
y es lo que hace esta obra auténtica y
es lo que hizo que esta obra me llegara
a ganar en japón en italia y ha sido muy
especial como no importa la cultura y no
importa la historia que tengas siempre
vas a conectar con lo más poderoso que
es el arte
bien decía mi amigo picasso que todo lo
que puedes imaginar es real y esta frase
se refiere a como nosotros nuestra mente
y nuestra persona es un imán es un imán
de ideas que están en el universo es un
imán de todas esas cosas positivas y
también negativas negativas que pensamos
es un imán de las personas de las que
nos rodeamos es un imán de las
situaciones que vemos pasar entonces
cómo vas a utilizar esta imaginación
esta historia que tienes para cambiar tu
mundo o el de los demás cómo vas a
utilizar esa historia triste que tienes
para transmitirse la otra persona lo vas
a hacer de manera positiva o lo vas a
hacer de manera negativa en las
películas siempre vemos las películas de
superhéroes hay siempre el villano y el
superhéroe el que pasó por una situación
difícil y utiliza esa situación y sale
adelante y ayuda a otras personas
tiene un superpoder que desarrolló a
través de un detonante que tuvo en su
vida y tenemos lo contrario
la persona que también sufrió mucho pero
que trata de llevar ese mismo daño a
otras personas y así es como sin irnos a
una película aquí tenemos personas que
han cambiado al mundo con su historia
para bien y personas que han cambiado el
mundo con su historia pero para mal
entonces en ese momento es donde tú
decides si cambias tu mundo y el de los
demás para bien o para mal tú decides y
terminas este ciclo de tristeza ese
ciclo de dolor o si ese ciclo va a
continuar infinitamente con otras
personas
el día de hoy me siento muy feliz de
poder compartir mi historia y mi
superpoder porque ese superpoder lo
tenemos todos yo todos los días me
levanto y trato de dejar de procrastinar
en esas ideas que tuve de niña y que
sentía que eran increíbles trato de
dejar de procrastinar en esos proyectos
que alguna vez alguien me dijo eso no
porque nadie lo ha hecho cómo te vas a
arriesgar a hacer eso es algo nuevo
todas las veces que alguien ha
descubierto algo y que ha hecho un
experimento lo ha hecho por primera vez
y lo ha logrado pero qué flojera fuera
si supiéramos todas las veces que esa
persona fallo todas las veces que esa
persona lo intentó miles de veces por
eso nos gusta solo escuchar las
historias maravillosas por eso solo nos
gusta escuchar lo bueno la parte buena
de la historia
el día de hoy quiero que te hagas esta
pregunta y todos los días que estás
haciendo el día de hoy para contar esa
historia que te hace diferente a los
demás qué estás haciendo el día de hoy
para desarrollar ese proyecto que tienes
desde hace años y que alguien te dijo
que no podía ser posible porque nadie
más lo había hecho que estás haciendo el
día de hoy para crecer tu imaginación y
empezar a pensar como niño como creativo
espero desde el día de mañana que tomes
20 minutos media hora si quieres menos
pero espero te tomes un tiempo a pensar
en esa idea dejarla de procrastinar y
que esa idea sea tan innovadora impacte
la mente y en la vida de tantas personas
que el próximo siglo o tal vez la
próxima generación crea que lo hicieron
los aliens gracias
[Aplausos]